It was a beautiful September day, but Shaun
Taylor was trapped in his car in one of the
worst cases of gridlock he had ever seen.
He tried to look on the bright side though,
and while he was stuck in an unmoving car,
at least he had a pleasant view of the wide,
shimmering lake just off the road next to
him.
He was admiring the scene when tiny drops
of rain started landing on his windshield.
That’s funny, there wasn’t a cloud in
the sky a moment ago.
There was something off about the rain though.
It looked dirty, a rusty red color.
Was that… blood?
He didn’t have time to think about it, because
just then a thick, dense mist began to roll
over the lake.
A fog of blood.
Just off the side of the road, he could see
a huge silhouette rising out of the water.
Is that an old submarine?
What Shaun didn’t know was that he was about
to have an encounter with SCP - 1861, also
known as The HMS Wintersheimer - a ghostly
submarine with strange and terrifying effects.
Shaun and the other drivers stuck in traffic
that day were far from the first people to
have a dangerous brush with this legendary
vessel - according to SCP Foundation records,
the HMS Wintersheimer has been appearing since
as early as 1916.
The first recorded incident occurred in the
British seaside town of Innsmouth-On-Sea.
You won’t find this town on any maps, or
in the history books, and you’re about to
find out why.
The 500-person population of the town, which
had already reduced by the wartime draft into
the currently-raging Great World War, awoke
to red skies on February 6th, 1916.
Citizens left their homes to investigate,
only to find their entire town had been enveloped
in a thick, red mist.
The swelling, crimson clouds up ahead began
to rain, showering the town in a hail of viscous,
red goop.
Anyone unlucky enough to taste it would say
that this strange rain was a dreadful mix
of salt and copper.
This was because, as the Foundation would
later determine, the rain and fog was a disgusting
combination of saltwater, human blood, and
human cerebrospinal fluid.
But the real threat was rising, just beyond
the beach.
Technically speaking, the HMS Wintersheimer
vessel is designated as SCP - 1861 - A. It
appears to be a World War One-era British
B-Class Submarine, designed by Vickers for
the Royal Navy in 1904.
By 1916, this particular type of boat was
already on its way to being obsolete, and
were largely deployed in Malta, far from the
active fronts.
So one of these vessels appearing on an otherwise
unremarkable stretch of English coastline
should have been a clue that something was
terribly wrong - but the poor residents of
Innsmouth-On-Sea didn’t know the half of
it.
Soon, figures in what appeared to be archaic
diving gear began emerging from the Wintersheimer,
and made their way into the township.
They seemed terrified, running up to and frantically
screaming at any local they could find.
“Please listen to me, something terrible
is about to happen here.
We need you to come with us or you’re all
going to die.
You must believe us!”
The locals were frightened by what they heard.
They’d been listening to news reports of
the Great War unfolding across the globe for
two years now.
Had it finally come to them?
They pictured shells raining down from the
sky, decimating their defenseless little town
in a rain of fire.
The Navy must have been brought in to save
them before the German bombardment began.
While some took more convincing than others,
the men in diving suits - known as SCP - 1861
- B - eventually managed to persuade the entire
town to join them, and lead the townspeople
down to the water.
One by one, they were all boarded onto the
submarine.
Hundreds of them.
Many couldn’t believe their eyes as they
watched scores of people disappear in front
of them into the dark bowels of the Wintersheimer.
Where were they all going?
How would they all fit in there?
But it was too late for any of them to back
out now.
The vessel submerged once more, and everyone
was gone.
The entire population of Innsmouth-On-Sea
had disappeared in a rain and fog of blood,
never to be seen again.
The Foundation wiped all records of the town
from existence and delivered appropriate amnestic
treatment to anyone who still mentioned or
remembered Innsmouth-On-Sea.
The fate of those who board the HMS Wintersheimer
is always the same - vanished from the face
of the earth, explained away by the Foundation
as “accidental death by extreme weather
event.”
There have been hundreds of documented sightings
of SCP - 1861, and the anomalous weather event
can occur near any body of water wide enough
to accommodate SCP-1861-A’s comms tower
and topmost platform.
Depth does not seem to be any hindrance to
the submarine appearing and it can even manifest
in water that’s just a few inches deep.
As Shaun and the other unfortunate victims
of the rush hour traffic were being showered
in thick, red droplets from above, a crimson
mist rolled in between the cars.
Shaun had heard of so-called freak weather
events before - like raining frogs and fish
- but this was something different, and it
frightened him.
He could see now that the silhouette rising
from the lake really was an old submarine,
and he watched as a legion of mysterious figures
disembarked from the vessel and began spilling
onto the road.
The men in ancient-looking diving suits walked
among the cars and one of them approached
Shaun’s car.
He began tapping frantically on the window
and Shaun could tell he was yelling something.
Shaun was scared and more, but more than anything
else, he was confused.
Against his better judgement, he rolled down
the window, just a crack, to hear what the
man was saying.
His British accented voice muted by the diving
suit, the man frantically told him “Sir!
Please listen to me!
I’m Lieutenant Samuel Ramsey of the HMS
Wintersheimer.
We're evacuating the area.
Please, you've got to come with me.
You're in danger out here.”
“HMS?”
Shaun thought, “isn’t that what they call
British ships?
What was a British submarine doing in the
middle of a lake in the United States?”
Through his windshield, Shaun could already
see other men in diving suits leading people
from the cars out towards the submarine.
Something had to be going on here.
Something big.
Lieutenant Ramsey was still banging away at
the glass of Shaun’s window, becoming increasingly
agitated.
“Sir, if you won’t comply with my orders,
I’m within my rights to take you by force
- for your own safety.”
Shaun could feel the fear setting in but he
didn’t know what else to do.
He turned off the car and took off his seatbelt.
He was just about to open the door when there
was a tap on the passenger side window of
his car.
It was a soldier in what looked to be advanced
tactical gear.
There were several soldiers directing cars
to drive on the shoulder to get around the
mess of stopped automobiles.
Shaun looked to his left and the man in the
diving suit was gone.
The soldier tapped again and Shaun didn’t
need to be told twice.
He followed his directions and drove around
the traffic jam and out of the mist.
A half mile down the road, Shaun was stopped
by another group of soldiers and given an
amnestic.
He drove away never knowing how close he had
come to vanishing in the bowels of SCP-1861-A.
Shaun was lucky that one of the SCP Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces had taken over the situation,
but they were too late to help those who had
already complied with SCP - 1861 - B’s orders
and boarded the Wintersheimer.
The Task Force made it their business to save
whoever they could, but that wasn’t their
only directive: The Foundation had recorded
a huge number of SCP - 1861 instances since
1916, and now, they were finally going to
figure out what was going on inside.
The Foundation had already discovered that
those taken onto the Wintersheimer don’t
simply disappear - once on board the submarine
they are forced into a diving suit of their
own, which transforms them into new instances
of SCP - 1861 - B. Upon realizing this, Foundation
scientists devised an ingenious plot.
Six months before this latest instance of
1861, the Foundation dispatched two members
of D-Class personnel who were familiar with
one another into the red mist.
One was instructed not to interact with SCP
- 1861 - B, while the other, named Sal, was
ordered to enter the submarine.
His mission was to report back all findings
to Foundation researcher Dr. Klutch during
the next 1861 event.
The D-Class who remained on shore was brought
in once more by the Mobile Task Force during
the September event that Shaun witnessed.
They checked each diving suit-wearing anomaly
until they heard a familiar voice, muffled
by the mask: It was Sal, and he’d been transformed
into an instance of SCP - 1861 - B. The human
D-Class, receiving questions from Dr. Klutch
via a remote broadcast, commenced the interview
of his former friend.
It is from this vital interview that much
of the Foundation’s knowledge of the mysterious
HMS Wintersheimer is drawn.
According to Sal, the interior of the Wintersheimer
- which is a long, narrow, passageway - is
a spatial anomaly that seems to stretch on
forever.
This explains how vast numbers of people,
like the entire population of Innsmouth-On-Sea,
can disappear into the submarine at once.
Sal reported that, about an hour after entering
the vessel, the hatch closed and the interior
began rapidly filling with water as the submarine
descended.Prisoners of the Wintersheimer were
faced with two choices: Suit up… or drown.
Few chose the latter option, and as soon as
the suit was on, the transformation had begun.
As soon as everyone was suited up and the
submarine had fully descended, causing the
1861 weather event to dissipate on earth,
the Wintersheimer had effectively entered
an alternate dimension.
The airlock opened, and the new recruits were
instructed to step outside and take a look
around.
The Wintersheimer veterans informed the new
sailors that everyone on land was likely already
dead by this point.
When Sal first exited the submarine, he commented
on everything around him looking eerily similar
to how it’d looked on land before the mist
descended.
But with one key difference: It seemed as
though everything was underwater.
Well, not quite that: It was almost as though
everything was water.
Like the world had taken on a kind of flowing,
liquid state.
Sal and the others existed in this otherworldly
land of living water for six months, and as
the months passed, things only got stranger.
They found that they neither needed to eat
nor sleep.
According to Sal, all they did was breathe
- and passed the time by exploring and talking
to one another.
Anyone who attempted to take off their suit
would dissolve and diffuse into the same liquid
that surrounded them.
Dr. Klutch asked Sal about the other inhabitants
of this alien realm and this was when things
got truly disturbing.
There were dead humans and animals floating
all over the place - missing their eyes, as
though they’d been scooped out, and missing
their mouths, as though they’d been bitten
out of their face by some kind of huge predator.
Their empty eye sockets bled constantly, and
Sal theorized that this may have something
to do with the anomalous blood mists of SCP
- 1861.
When asked to provide more information on
why all the corpses were mutilated in this
way, Sal said that one of his superiors on
the Wintersheimer told him “the watcher
of eyes and biter of teeth deemed them worthy.”
Whatever this mysterious being was, it seemed
to be a powerful figure within 1861’s water
world, and Sal felt lucky that he had never
had a direct run-in with the creature himself.
For his final request, Dr. Klutch asked Sal
to attempt to remove his suit.
The Foundation had learned in previous instances
of 1861 that the diving suits have anomalous
durability, and it was impossible for anyone
other than the wearer to remove them - hence
why the Foundation could never deal with 1861-B
by using brute force.
Naturally, Klutch was interested in finding
out what was going on underneath.
Sal expressed fear and anxiety at first, wondering
if after all he’d been through whether he
could even be considered human anymore.
Eventually, he was convinced to remove the
suit, and his worst fears were confirmed.
The second Sal removed his helmet, gallons
of seawater poured out and the now empty suit
collapsed to the ground.
Sal’s body was ever found - only some teeth
and a pair of eyes were recovered.
The eyes were later confirmed as belonging
to a young girl, and the teeth were identified
as having come from European red deer.
And so the dark mystery of the HMS Wintersheimer
continues.
Because of the unpredictable nature of its
appearances, and the resulting difficulty
of containing it, the Wintersheimer has earned
a Keter Classification.
The only containment procedure currently employed
by the SCP Foundation is for Mobile Task Forces
to try and intercept the submarine when appearances
are reported, and hopefully prevent or at
least reduce the kidnapping of civilians.
With so many questions left unanswered.
All we can say for certain is that if a red
mist ever descends on you and a stranger in
a diving suit tells you that you’re in grave
danger - he’s absolutely right.
Now go check out “SCP - 035 - The Possessive
Mask” and “SCP - 087 - The Stairwell”
for more freaky stories from the SCP Foundation!